good morning believe nation today's
message is be a sponge over to you Chris
Pratt you know some jobs you learn by
going to college and they give you an
education then you bring that to work
and some jobs you learn by just being on
the job and from curst part three on all
the way up to Jurassic world my
knowledge of how to be on a set how to
act and how to handle myself on set and
approach work is continuing to grow I've
learned a lot on every job it would be
smart went on a job to be a sponge pick
somebody and learn from it I'm getting
the point now where I have more
experience than a lot of the people that
are on the set and I'm actually at a
point where I can teach other people so
that's pretty cool too so one of my
favorite success principles things that
I love doing is modeling success one of
the fastest ways to accomplish any goal
is to find someone who's already done it
and go learn from them see what they did
in the early stages where you are right
now what did they do to get to there and
how can you apply those strategies to
your situation right now it's one of the
fastest ways to grow and the good news
is whatever problem you're facing right
now it's already been solved somebody's
already figured it out you have to find
their story read their book watch your
video listener interview go to their
presentation whatever it is to learn it
and then apply it to yourself and so I
love the idea of being a sponge when
you're around somebody who's done a lot
more and I think too many people are you
know breezing through a book and are
paying attention to the words and it's
like what we're in the last five pages I
don't remember and you just keep going
on or you're watching one of these
videos you're watching a top ten on
somebody that you really want to learn
from and you're doing Photoshop or
trying to write an article or doing some
other computer work while you're trying
to listen to this advice like if you
really want to learn from that person
shut everything off and focus it's gonna
make a big difference how many of the
videos have you watched that we're just
in the background playing why are you
doing something now
and if somebody asks you hey what
happened in the past five minutes you
know so the fact that you have it on in
the background maybe this little bit of
learning that's happening but if that's
somewhere that you really really want to
learn from then focus be a sponge you
know to get to some of those videos
we've done hours and hours and hours and
hours of research now if you don't like
the person you like their message you're
not learning from some of the first
points don't keep watching it right move
on to something else
but if you have the opportunity to be
around someone who's done something
great
absorbent too many people are just
thinking about what they're doing next
or the other responsibilities they have
and you're missing out on a golden
opportunity to really learn something
and to help you in your life and your
business or whatever goal that you have
so the question today today is I'm
curious how much of this content how
much of my videos are you actively
consuming and paying attention to or
just have on in the background I'm
curious I might be in for a surprise
leave it in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion finally want to
give a quick shout out to Edwin Edwin is
actually one of our assistants at
Toronto dance salsa
Edwin thank you so much for picking up a
cup of my book really really really
means a lot to me bro so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in
yourselves and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
vessel
miss Bristow Kegel